how much specialization is there
maybe if i give you like two choices is
it good to have like one throw
and try to become the best person in the
world at that throw or do you want to
have a bunch of stuff
uh like a a variety of throws well for
travis it was ipo and saying that was
his main throw right but from that ipo
and saying he had a variety of other
attacks he could do
you know that mixed it up so that you
kept people guessing it maybe it wasn't
the palm see we was coming maybe it was
the koshi grumma that he did or maybe it
was the iphone to osoto that he did in
combination so you typically have one
main throw that you do for me it was
taotoshi for kayla it was her ogoshi for
travis it was ipo and sanagi but then
you come up with a variety of other
throws that you do from the very same
grip so whatever grip you take for your
main throw you want to develop you know
an arsenal of attacks that go in all
different directions holding that same
grip
so you keep your opponent guessing as to
what's coming you know because if
they're just sitting on one technique
at the highest level of sport with the
exception of a few right we talked about
ono's uchimada
with the exception of a few most of the
world catches on pretty quick on how to
beat you
there is something to just sticking
making sure you really dedicate to the
main thing so for travis that would be
like the main version of his inagi
like really making sure you don't forget
to really put in the time on that
because um
i mean one one way to say it is
that threat being dangerous opens up a
lot of things right
but also
i don't know
i think i'm just as a fan i think it
it's sad when like elite level athletes
in in all like combat sports
kind of start taking their main thing
for granted
like um they think okay i've i figured
that part out
now i'll be working on this whole system
on variations on different setups on uh
lefty versus some like weird variation
as opposed to
you know what if you look at some of the
best people ever they seem to have not
cared about variations at all
they're just like literally
they are more like giro dreams of sushi
and like
like fine-tuning their ear their ability
to detect the minute movements that give
you an opening on that main thing and so
the whole time you're just
waiting for that throw you're like
dancing with the like little bit of
pressure
and that like releasing the pressure and
putting the pressure maybe a little bit
off off balance and finding like the
right
moment to strike and and focusing on
that again maybe that's just like a
romanticization of like
the simplicity of that maybe it is kind
of impossible to do that on a large
scale but i just
um yeah i i don't know if you can
comment on that whether there is some
value and still putting in like tens of
thousands of reps on the main main thing
well unquestionably that has to happen
you still have to drill your main throw
and you have to fine tune it and
continue to do you know repetition after
repetition and throws on the crash pad
you know or throws on the mat moving
around just explosive movements doing
your main technique you're never going
to forget that and you're not going to
put it to the side and not practice it
anymore it still has to be part of your
repertoire
and part of your daily training
but you do have to evolve and i think
that's and i think that's the sport of
judo makes you evolve you know when i
look at we talk about koga from before
right and we talked about he had a
dynamic ipo and say inagi that nobody
could stop for years and years and years
but when people started to you know be
unorthodox and come down his back and
cross-grip him and he couldn't get to
the lapel he had to come up with
something else and all of a sudden you
saw koga doing now he did a soda where
now he did a tomoynagi which so he can
he added to his arsenal you know to keep
people thinking keep hillary gas in so
it's not you're not just that one trick
pony they still couldn't stop his ipo
and say
once he got that grip but if they
stopped him from getting that grip or
putting two hands on the ghee he had to
go to something else and that's what he
did does uh travis's or koga's say nagi
make sense to you
that weird uh so when i because split
hip that's right hips
so
i don't know if you know this but like i
got into judo because of travis i
watched him with 2008 olympics and i was
uh there's something about like
uh just the not the cockiness but the
confidence and just the refusal to quit
the refusal to just some that energy
whatever it connected with me is like oh
that guy's badass
i want to be badass like that
and then i also there happened to be in
my university judo and i um
and i got into and just fell in love
with the elegance and the beauty and the
power of the sport
um
but also i started to mimic travis's
game uh his and koga's
and i and then uh the instructors i
worked with they said that's the wrong
way to do it
and i always i never found somebody that
told me that like
no that's not the wrong way to there's a
lot of ways to do it and there's like
the classic way and you have to
understand and you have to learn it but
this is not the wrong way because i was
trying to find somebody who understands
this throw um
because it's so
beautiful at the highest level
especially with koga the way
you're able the the quickness with which
you can strike the fact that you could
stand on the feet and the elevation you
can get and the power you can get it has
certain throws
just
like uchamada doesn't look powerful
it it's just like it's it looks
effortless
but like
the standing sanagi with a split hip it
just looks powerful because
there's a
you you're like you're stepping into
them you're lifting the opponent and
they still have they're not surprised
they're now like helpless right their
feet are fluttering they're flattering
so and then there's just this this pause
and then just big slam
with the ushimata it's almost like you
don't know what hit you
that's like tayatoshi is the same it's
almost like a surprise like oh [ __ ] i'm
not on my back
and um
so i i just i just
love that throw but like
i it didn't make sense to me
like
when trying to explain it to others when
trying to learn it didn't make sense to
me
how it works does it make sense to you
it does yeah i'm a i was born a judoka
right so i i've lived this stuff since i
was
an infant um and i've seen every style
and every technique um
the split hip saying aggie is is
difficult to learn it's harder to learn
than the the basic form but it is
powerful and it does
upon entry
both your opponent's feet leave them out
at the same time so you've got them once
you enter you've got them you just got
to finish right you just got to lock
them and turn and go so it makes sense
to me my dad did teach me how to do that
when i was younger yeah he wanted me to
do a split hip we have kids at the
school today that we teach the split hip
say in aggie same way
because it is that dynamic right you
don't drop to the ground and roll and
turn it's not the classic form where
you're giving way to your opponent it's
actually you go pick the guy up in the
air and then you slam them so
you